hi I'm Brendan Fraser that's Fraser
sounds like Razer which has been
mispronounced all my career I'm glad we
were able to clear this up and here's my
PSA on words that you might be saying
wrong first up let's clarify it's
nuclear not nuclear people
Antarctic not actually it's not
pronounced Antarctic next up it's cash
not cachet cachet is actually French for
hide next oh this one always gets me too
and I'm from Seattle espresso not
expresso that's an honest mistake and
for the love of Pete can you say move
not move it's actually the other way
around mauve not move jewelry not
jewelry for all intensive purposes it's
actually pronounced for all intents and
purposes and I know that because it says
so right here I'm Brandon Fraser it's
pronunciation not pronunciation it's a
Canadian thing okay thanks bye